just a handful of notes with just the
right combination can night a group of
total strangers in the darkened theater
movie theater and I was blessed to have
gone to the USS the University of Steven
Spielberg when we coal produces the
color purple and we used to refer to the
music as emotional ocean not a mean
Waddell this year's exceptional
compositions are sure to bring that
special sense of shared experience to
audiences for years to come
here are the nominees for Best Original
Score bridge of spies by Thomas Newman
Carol by Carter burrow Sicario by johann
johansson
by anymore
Star Wars The Force awakens by John
Williams and the Oscar goes to in the
old Morricone the hateful eight
practically no
this is the first Oscar and sixth
nomination for any amour
we also received an honorary award in
recognition of his magnificent and
multifaceted contributions to the art of
film music
marked on it
poor Sara senior Ebola Sara Brekke so
residues or ecology Mentos thank you the
Academy for this prestigious
acknowledgement a mobile survey al
criminality in particular a lost Amado
John Williams my tribute goes to the
other nominees and Percival to the
steamed John Williams nan Chi hoon
Amasya important sent some Rando film
the Gillespie
there isn't a great soundtrack without a
great movie that inspires it regret win
team Tarantino Pirelli shell toe here we
wasting to tech team again race or
possibly with asteroid Ilario film
I want to thank Quentin Tarantino for
having chosen me
are we Weinstein and the entire team who
made this extraordinary film dead ago
resto film Christo Esteban Zia Equus a
Victoria a loss car Amelia Maria a
dedicated is a word to my wife Maria
with the watch me see thank you